Transcription: Claire Azam
Relecteur: eric vautier
(Applaudissements)
« Quel temps pourri, vous trouvez pas?
Quelle vie de merde, y'en a ras de bol !
Pas vous ? »
Mon chauffeur de taxi semble s'être levé
du mauvais pied.
C'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Instantanément, mon plexus se bloque,
mon pouls s'accélère.
Pour autant, je ne me laisse pas piéger
par une réaction épidermique
qui ne manquerait pas d'alimenter
son humeur grise.
Bon, vous me direz,
je n'ai pas beaucoup de mérite.
Hier encore, je m'extasiais à la vue
d'une vallée majestueuse
pictée de girafes à la robe étoilée.
Les hautes herbes rouges et jaunes
ondulaient dans le vent avec grâce.
Ouais, pour tout vous dire, je reviens
du Kenya, de chez les Maasaï,
vous savez, ces fameux guerriers
assoiffés de sang et de trophées.
Ces bêtes de proie magnifiques
mais dangereuses.
Bon, je plaisante.
Là, c'est le mythe dans lequel
on les enferme,
on enferme ces pasteurs-nomades
emblématiques d'Afrique de l'est
depuis un siècle et demi.
Non, moi si j'y retourne depuis
si longtemps,
c'est parce qu'à l'inverse de
ce cliché grotesque,
je suis porteur d'un virus très doux,
très humain
qu'ils m'ont transmis
lorsque j'étais enfant.
Et qu'un Anglais passionné... maladie
d'amour qu'un Anglais passionné
a baptisé « massaïtis »
dans les années 1940.
Pour la petite histoire,
les administrateurs anglais
de la réserve maasaï
au temps de la colonie
voyaient régulièrement
leur autorité sapée par ce mal étrange.
Au point
que la reine d’Angleterre elle-même
dû prendre un décret royal
leur interdisant de rester en poste
plus de trois mois.
De la même façon,
cette maladie d'amour pour les Maasaï
a sapé chez moi toute velléité
de rester sur les rails
d'un statut social tout tracé,
préférant demeurer libre,
sensible et en accord avec moi-même.
Laissez-moi vous donner
quelques temps forts de mon itinéraire.
Ça va être très rapide.
À l'age de six ans, je me noie,
puis je reviens à la vie.
Je fais alors un rêve étrange
jusqu'à l'adolescence,
où je prends mon envol avec un homme noir
drapé de rouge.
Plus tard, guidé par tant de signes,
je décide de faire
de longues études anthropologiques,
avec pour unique objectif
d'aller partager leur vie.
Ce que je fais durant trois années.
Trois années au cœur de la savane
parmi leurs immenses troupeaux de vaches,
faune sauvage en abondance.
Alors inutile de vous dire que
leur joie de vivre très contagieuse
n'a fait qu’accroître mon état d'addiction
aux Maasaï.
Celui-ci deviendra d'ailleurs très vite
irréversible au point que,
une décennie plus tard,
je déciderai de démissionner
de toutes mes fonctions universitaires,
et Dieu sait si elles étaient nombreuses,
pour transmettre en toute liberté,
comme je le fais ce soir devant vous,
et pour la première fois certainement,
je parle des Maasaï -
les vertus de ce merveilleux virus.
On l'aurait presque oublié
mais je suis toujours dans mon taxi !
L'ambiance y est lourde.
Je préfère repenser
à la magnifique bénédiction
que m'a susurrée hier un vénérable sage
à la première lueur de l'aurore.
« Salutations, aube céleste !
Laisse la sensibilité de notre ami
s'épanouir
à l'image de ton ascension lente et sûre.
Laisse-la grandir sans bruit. »
Alors dans mon taxi je me dis :
si au lieu de m'énerver,
je prenais sur moi de garder mon calme ?
Et si je considérais mon chauffeur
avec amour, avec empathie ?
Si finalement ce que l'on dégageait
avait un impact déterminant
sur le comportement des autres ?
Je me concentre sur la route qui défile,
puis je ferme les yeux
pour mieux me remémorer
tous les bons moments
que je viens de passer au Kenya.
Le résultat ne se fait pas attendre.
Une vague de paix me submerge soudain.
Quant à mon chauffeur, petit miracle ?
coïncidence ? Je ne sais pas.
Son ton a subitement changé.
Il semble s'être apaisé d'un seul coup.
Comment ne pas faire le lien avec
une histoire incroyable qui m'est arrivée
il y a quelques années
sur les escaliers de Montmartre !
Rien que de vous en parler,
j'ai les images qui défilent
comme si je les revivais
avec vous ce soir.
Une douzaine d'hommes
aux épaules de dockers...
Je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà vu
des hommes aux épaules de dockers...
C'est moi !
(Rires)
Ne riez pas ! Ne riez pas !
En tout cas, ils étaient douze.
Ils se ruent sur moi en me menaçant
de leurs couteaux à cran d'arrêt.
Je ne vais pas le faire devant vous.
C'était moi, la cible.
Ils se ruent sur moi et me dépouillent
presque entièrement de pied en cap.
Je suis mort de trouille.
Mais l’adrénaline a beau me noyer,
je n'ai de cesse de m'adresser à eux
avec douceur, amour, empathie, tendresse.
Je m'entends même leur expliquer
que ce n'est pas de leur faute.
Que dans nos pays dits développés,
être quelqu'un, c'est porter un masque.
Être un homme,
c'est faire semblant d'être fort.
C'est ne pas pleurer.
Que tout petit déjà,
on nous apprend à vivre séparés,
coupés de la source pleine de tendresse
qui nous unit tous, pour avancer.
Mais vers où ? Pourquoi ?
Et dans quel but ?
Contre toute attente,
ils baissent leur garde.
J'en profite d'ailleurs pour
leur demander :
« Dites, vous pourriez
me rendre ma montre ?
Elle m'a été donnée par ma grand-mère
le jour de ma communion solennelle
et j'y tiens comme à la prunelle
de mes yeux. »
Imaginez un peu tous ces fiers-à-bras,
ces armoires à glace, comme moi,
fondre d'un seul coup,
devenir tout penauds
et venir la tête basse me rendre
à la queue-leu-leu,
tout ce qu'ils m'ont dérobé.
Qui ma montre, qui mon blouson,
qui mes chaussures,
en se confondant en excuses
et en finissant par me réclamer,
comme on réclame une faveur :
« Monsieur, vous n'auriez pas dix balles,
s'il vous plait ? »
Chez les Maasaï, j'ai appris
qu'il est normal et efficace
de considérer l'autre
comme le prolongement de soi-même.
Me voilà donc dans mon taxi,
toujours, sur le périphérique.
Il pleut à verse.
Mon chauffeur me crie :
« Vous arrivez d'où déjà ?
- Du Kenya. »
Le silence s'installe,
que je ne cherche pas à meubler.
Puis à ma grande surprise, il enchaîne
par deux, trois phrases
déclamées avec de la joie.
Presque de la ferveur.
« Le Kenya, dites-vous !
Vous en avez de la chance !
Vous avez raison de partir là-bas.
C'est un pays merveilleux.
C'est un vrai jardin d’Éden.
D'ailleurs, je crois bien avoir visionné
tous les documentaires animaliers
sur ce beau pays.
Et en plus, il y a du soleil
toute l'année ! »
Je suis soudain rempli d’allégresse,
d'enthousiasme.
C'est comme si j'avais bu
un peu trop de champagne.
Mon être pétille.
Chez les Maasaï, cette exaltation
est le produit d'une inspiration divine.
C'est leur Dieu féminin intérieur
qui leur permet d'avoir,
comme ils disent
avec infiniment de respect,
le regard clair et la démarche alerte.
Produits non pas d'une arrogance,
mais d'une construction intime
d'homme libre
qui est tout simplement heureux
de partager sa liberté avec les autres.
Pour cela, nul besoin de long discours.
C'est au Kosovo,
après les frappes de l'OTAN,
que j'ai sans doute eu le privilège
de l'expérimenter avec le plus de force
et le plus de succès.
J'ai organisé
des réunions de réconciliation.
Un jour, je me mets d'accord
avec mon binôme
pour qu'il anime la séance tandis que moi,
je m'exprime au travers de mon silence.
J'ai devant moi des leaders serbes
assez menaçants,
qui me font d'ailleurs davantage penser
à de sinistres guerriers
qu'à des colombes de la paix.
M'enfin... je n’en mène pas large.
Je commence par conséquent à exécuter
en mon for intérieur,
un rituel Maasaï de purification, que
je connais bien, qui s'appelle encopito
pour que je retrouve ma joie intérieure
de telle sorte à ce que leur négativité
n'ait plus de prise sur moi
et que même elle finisse
par disparaître chez eux.
Rituel qui consiste
à nouer symboliquement son cœur,
afin d'y enfermer le bien et le mal.
Pour les Maasaï,
lorsque vous mettez ensemble
le bien et le mal au plus profond
de votre coeur,
tout ce qui n'est pas conforme,
tout ce qui n'est pas correct
se dissout de lui-même, s'autodétruit.
Durant toute la réunion,
mon être vibre
autour d'une seule pensée :
« Prenez-vous dans les bras
les uns les autres,
et faites parler votre véritable nature
qui est d'aimer sans restriction. »
Au bout de deux heures, à ma grande joie,
à ma grande stupéfaction,
la plupart des leaders serbes se lèvent
et viennent demander pardon
à l'autre camp.
J'en pleure à chaudes larmes.
Pour moi, c'est parce qu'ils ont accepté
de vivre l'instant au lieu de le juger.
Renonçant ainsi,
aux barrières que l'Histoire
avait dressées dans leurs têtes
pour obéir enfin à leur sensibilité.
En pays Maasaï,
faire silence est une pratique courante.
D'ailleurs, leurs porte-paroles
les plus respectés
sont ceux-là même qui ne parlent pas.
J'ai maintes fois eu l'occasion
de le constater, bien sûr.
Leur simple présence débordant d'amour,
de sensibilité, suffit généralement
à réconcilier les pires ennemis
et à réveiller les cœurs
les plus récalcitrants.
Pour les Maasaï, nous ne pouvons vivre
en harmonie avec nous-même
et avec les autres,
que si nous laissons notre sensibilité,
source de créativité et de construction,
guider notre ego.
C'est elle, notre sensibilité,
qui permet de libérer
tout l'amour qui est en nous.
Et pour cela, quoi de mieux
que le silence ?
Oui, quoi de mieux que le silence ?
Mon chauffeur de taxi interrompt là
ma méditation.
Il me lance comme une évidence :
« Ah le Kenya, le Kenya...
Vous m'avez tant fait rêver avec ce pays,
vous m'avez tant appris
de choses sur ce pays,
vraiment, je n'ai plus qu'une idée
en tête, c'est aussi partir à mon tour. »
Mais pourtant je réfléchis, je ne lui ai
pratiquement pas adressé la parole
depuis l'aéroport
Roissy-Charles de Gaulle !
Alors décidément, que ce soit
les pickpockets de Montmartre,
les leaders serbes,
et maintenant mon chauffeur de taxi,
il me paraît évident
que c'est la solution intérieure
qui est la plus efficace pour changer
positivement le cours des choses.
Imaginons ce qu'aurait été le Kenya
si la Reine d'Angleterre
n’avait pas édicté son décret royal,
interdisant aux administrateurs coloniaux
de la réserve Maasaï
de rester en poste plus de trois mois,
de peur
qu'ils ne tombent amoureux de ce peuple.
Qu'ils ne contractent la célèbre
« Maasaïtis » et qu'ils fassent silence,
tout comme ces pasteurs nomades
qu'ils étaient censés gouverner.
Imaginons comment pourrait fonctionner
le monde, notre planète,
si nous abandonnions,
nous laissions tomber
notre vouloir tout contrôler ?
Si nous donnions libre court
à notre sensibilité, enfin.
Je l'ai vérifié auprès des physiciens
de physique quantique.
Pour eux, il n'y a aucun doute :
il existe bel et bien
une reliance universelle
entre tous les êtres vivants
qui nous permet d'agir sur le monde
par notre transformation personnelle.
Alors ce soir, j'ai envie
de vous faire le cadeau
de cette extraordinaire leçon de vie
que j'ai fait mienne.
Cajolons notre sensibilité,
notre bien le plus précieux.
Connectons-nous à elle en conscience,
dans toutes nos situations,
même les plus difficiles.
Nous réaliserons alors
ce que les Maasaï appellent
la « communion sacrée »
entre notre sensibilité et l'amour
qui est la source de toute chose.
Nous aurons vaincu nos peurs.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)